in our morning rounds we are looking out
looking at
surprise out of network medical bills
in our continuing bill of the month
partnership with kaiser health news and
npr
we examine a case where one patient says
she received an unexpected medical bill
after having knee surgery
izzy bonasso's insurance company cigna
was built
ninety six thousand dollars three
hundred and thirty ninety six thousand
three hundred thirty seven dollars by
the hospital
bonasso ended up paying 357
out of pocket for the surgery but she
also received notice on an additional
charge from an
out-of-network surgical assistant who
was part of her operation
i pivoted and
reach for a ball and i couldn't
straighten my knee after that
last summer 21 year old izzy bonasso
tore her meniscus playing tennis
she needed immediate surgery when the
hospital called
i clarified with them that the surgeon
and the hospital
and anyone would be working with me was
in network
but a month later benasso says she
learned that wasn't the case
she received two letters from eric
griffin a surgical assistant who was
in the er during her surgery griffin who
is not
in network stated he would be billing
bonasso's insurance provider
cigna he charged cigna 1167.
now this was separate from bonasso's
surgery bill
i'd never seen anything like it before
benasso's father steve responded to
griffith telling him
to work things out with the in-network
surgeon who hired him
her surgeon declined our request for
comment
he was trying to collect money from
cigna but i suspected that if he didn't
get anything from sigma he was going to
try and collect from us
cigna approved griffith's claim and
applied his fee to the bonasso's
outpatient deductible despite the
letters the bonasso's never received a
bill from griffin
or cigna i don't expect to hear from him
and i certainly don't intend to pay
i think a lot of times with medical
billing you
you know get scared that you owe
something and you pay it immediately or
at least that's how it seems i mean if i
was alone in this and without
my dad to kind of help me out i think i
probably would have seen that letter and
got scared
a spokesperson for the hospital says
quote it is a responsibility of the
surgeon
to pre-authorize the surgery and to
discuss the use of a surgical assistant
with the patient
during preoperative procedures surgical
assistants are not employed by the
hospital
the out-of-network surgical assistant
eric griffin says in a statement
that before the surgery ms benasso
signed a form acknowledging my presence
and that she was aware that i was an
out-of-network provider
the form in which ms benasso signed
including all my contact
information if she or the family had any
questions surrounding the use of an
out-of-network assistant
or my billing practices griffith says
the form also states
that the maximum she would be
responsible for is 250
and to date she has not been billed by
him for any amount
the editor-in-chief of kaiser health
news that's dr elizabeth rosenthal joins
us now to discuss
this sounds a little confusing you know
when you're in the hospital and you're
about to go in and
sign a form and then they say look you
already signed it so you knew i was
going to be there
how often does this happen it seems to
happen quite a bit
oh it happens all the time because you
know she
or in general people are presented with
this pile of forms
as you're going into surgery and what
are you going to do like you're
anticipating your surgery you're going
to read through them like legal
documents and be sherlock holmes
it's really not fair so and often the
side the these forms
are very vague they'll say you may have
an out-of-network
participant in your surgery so you know
it's just not fair to patients
so are they supposed to disclose that to
you elizabeth
ahead of time they're saying that they
did exactly that
well um again it's in a pile of forms
somewhere
and these forms are handed to you as at
your pre-op check
you know your surgeries an hour away so
i think
you know the burden should be on the
hospital and on
the doctor and i think everyone's
passing the buck here it's like oh yeah
we told her
but you know you can't expect patients
to do a major investigation when they're
doped up and nervous about their surgery
and that's what we're asking them to do
and i think the thing is here i was
going to use the idea of asking about
you know is the er doctor a network
because we know that can happen you go
to an in-network er
and there's an out-of-network doctor but
in this case this was an assistant
in the operating room she didn't even
know the person was there she's out
cold so i i think it really takes
things to a new level and puts the
responsibility on the patient in a way
that's
just not fair i know you really are very
nervous and very vulnerable at that time
it seems like there should be a better
way to do this
so what do you do if you get a surprise
medical bill like that
well i think the thing is um yes you
have to read things very carefully and
instead of signing forms you should say
will there be anyone out of network
participating in my care
in any way and if their answer is no
there won't
then then you should not pay these bills
and i think the thing is you know when
we're getting to territory
in the old days the person who helped a
surgeon would be employed by the
hospital
or it'd be a medical resident like i was
now these people are independent
contractors and they're billing
independently
and that's just not right i think the
hospital needs to take responsibility
for this
hire people hire their own surgical
assistants
or have the doctor hire a surgical
assistant who is in the same network so
patients don't get stuck
so my first check my first um you know a
piece of advice in this series is always
don't just write the check but that's
sad to have to tell people that
i know and at the time i want to know
in-network out of network i just want
somebody who will do a good job and
help me at this particular time got a
lot going on
in in those moments thank you dr
elizabeth rosenthal always good to see
you